so let's talk about the senate huge
senate news
over the weekend according to the latest
update
from the non-partisan cook political
report democrats are now
slightly favored to take control of the
senate from republicans in november now
what does this mean for
us nothing everyone has to vote no
matter what is going on
but let's actually discuss so back in
2019
i didn't think democrats had a good shot
at taking the senate in 2020
um we have 100 senators every two years
one-third of them are up for re-election
and the third of the seats that were up
in 2020
were not in early 2019 looking very
favorable for democrats trump was
polling okay enough
that the incumbent republicans weren't
being hugely hurt and i did a story in
may of 2019 called
why democrats won't take the senate in
2020 and in the clip i say
this is the situation right now if
something changes i will update you
and then things sort of did change and
some seats started looking not quite so
good for incumbent republicans trump
wasn't doing so hot
and so by october of 2019 i did another
close analysis of each race each seat up
for re-election
and that got me to a point where i
revised my view
and told you in october of 2019
democrats could
take the senate in 2020. now
i've been following this closely for you
since and in may
of this year just a couple months ago i
did a story where
there was an uphill battle certainly but
a much clearer path for democrats to
take the senate and again i came back to
you on may 20th and i said
democrats could take the senate from
republicans and it was uphill but it was
a much more reasonable path
and things have now gotten so bad
for donald trump and incumbent
republicans even loosely associated with
him in the last two months since that
story that the cook political report
100 days out from this election now says
that democrats are favored to take back
the senate
now it's a slim margin but a slight edge
to democrats to take back the senate
is a dramatically different situation
than what we had 18 months ago now as a
reminder
right now the senate is 53 to 47
republicans over democrats of the 47
that i'm including on the democratic
side
it's actually 45 democrats plus two
independents
uh angus king and that guy bernie
sanders who are independents but caucus
with democrats that's where you get 47
democrats
and 53 republicans in july
five races changed in such a way that
the cook political report
changed their projection to a slight
edge
to democrats to control the senate the
changes in july
are in arizona martha mcsally
is losing pretty badly to mark kelly in
polls
and that has gone from a toss-up to
leaning democratic
in iowa joni ernst the incumbent
republican that race has gone from
leaning republican to a toss-up
in georgia david perdue's race has gone
from leaning republican to
a toss-up in minneapolis in minnesota
rather
tina smith went from likely democratic
victory to
solid democratic victory and then in new
mexico which is currently an open seat
uh it went from likely democrat tom
udall winning
to solidly democrat tom udall winning
now those are the changes in july
which have pushed the senate overall to
more likely to be taken control of by
democrats but
you've got a whole bunch of other races
that have not changed in july which
we've talked about colorado and north
carolina
are very vulnerable republican seats
that's cory gardner
and uh tom tillis uh those are leaning
democratic
in maine susan collins is in a real
uphill battle probably her toughest
re-election campaign
really ever i believe susan collins was
first elected don't hold me to this but
i believe 96
meaning she had re-election campaigns in
2002
2008 2014 that makes sense and 2020
all of her other re-election campaigns
have been not particularly challenging
for her and sarah gideon at least in
some polls recently is actually ahead so
maine a tough one for republicans to
hold and really
maine should not have a republican
senator we they should replace uh
susan collins as soon as possible we've
talked about montana where
democrat steve bullock is doing well he
could end up being senator from montana
there are question marks around seats in
kansas
texas alaska and south carolina so
there's a whole bunch of different
possibilities and the point of this
story is not about
analyzing each of them in extreme detail
but about the idea
that what looked you know in early 2019
the data was saying maybe democrats can
pick up a seat or two
but taking control would probably be
2022.
uh and 2022 doesn't even look that
obviously great depending on which
states you're looking at
it shifted to there's a path
but all these different maybes need to
go the way of the democratic
challengers it is now shifted to you
know there's more races leaning
democratic and now you don't need as
much of a performance
outside of what would be reasonable to
take control of the senate and so that's
how now it is being called a
slight edge for democrats in the cook
political report so
this is all a way of me telling you what
to stay home and say
other people got it no of course not
this is a way of me saying
hey here is an opportunity
which we will only seize if we all go
out and vote
ignore every poll and go out and vote if
you don't like the republican
senator that is representing your state
right now ignore the polls
and vote and we'll keep covering the
senate outlook and the
this is particularly important because
of the conversation we had at the top of
the show
if joe biden wins him doing stuff
that we want him to do is going to
depend hugely on having the senate in
the first two years in office
historically when the white house
changes hands
in an election year two years later in
those midterms
that party that took control of the
white house often suffers losses
in the house and or senate we don't want
that
but what we can do in the immediate is
let's give joe biden if he were to win
a senate that is democratically
controlled and a house that is
democratically controlled if that
happens
the two years between january 21st uh
january 20th
2021 and january 2023
may be the biggest opportunity for
progressive change
in decades in the united states well i
guess we would put it up there
with the couple years between 2009 and
2011 when barack obama had the
opportunity
uh mishandled some things but also got
many things done
including obamacare so that's the
opportunity this is absolutely huge and
all you have to do is go vote you know
it can be overwhelming oh
tom udall and then martha mcsally and
all the
i can't focus on your scope of influence
focus on your sphere of influence which
is
am i allowed to vote oh i am because you
know i'm a citizen obviously
you can if you're if you're legally
voting then that's what you should do
i'm going to go and vote and that's all
i can control and then i can work on get
out the vote
and i can work on whatever else work on
what you can control and we have a real
opportunity here
real quick i want to tell you about our
sponsor magic spoon
who have done something awesome they've
taken all of our favorite sugary
childhood cereals
that we know we shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult there's four flavors
cocoa fruity frosted and blueberry they
taste great they're crunchy
they're sweet like you would expect this
type of cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only
three net carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free
gluten-free grain-free soy-free
once our team tried magic spoon for the
first time we actually ended up emailing
magic spoon back and saying can you send
us
more boxes send more samples they've
been a big hit
with david pakman show staffers and
magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked
and you'll get free shipping when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n